gluten-free diets that cut out all food
with wheat barley and rye have become
extremely popular in the last couple
years so we challenged four people to
change their diet for a month to see
what happens when you go gluten-free
i've heard that going gluten-free helps
you get more energetic which is
definitely something i'm interested in
because i'm always tired i want to kind
of get back onto a healthy eating
schedule and really pay more attention
to what i'm putting in my body i'm
excited to just find like good
gluten-free cake the reason i want to go
gluten-free is because my girlfriend was
diagnosed with celiac disease
and i'm hoping that by myself going
gluten-free i can make a little bit
easier for her
what are some changes that i should
expect when going gluten-free it depends
on how sensitive your body is to gluten
but some of the great benefits of being
gluten-free are increased energy a lot
of people who go on a gluten-free diet
end up having more energy just because
the energy in their body isn't being
used for digestion i'm nervous that i'm
not going to have a lot to eat think
about it this way our favorite foods
become our favorite foods because we eat
them often the good news for you is
you're not giving up your five favorite
you're just setting it aside and saying
oh do i have 20 other favorites that i
didn't even know about so you come out
of the diet and you've got 25 favorites
i was just looking at my favorite fake
bacon that i eat all the time modern
corn starch wheat gluten i had no idea
there was gluten in this i might have
eaten some since i started the diet
i definitely have at work we had free
cupcake day so after i like pouted about
that quietly to myself i suddenly found
out there was a gluten-free option
there's gluten-free options of a lot of
stuff but there's just one gluten-free
option i found it's made my life about
60
more annoying it's friday at buzzfeed a
ton of free donuts right here and i
can't eat them because i'm gluten free
this month physically i feel exactly the
same i do
not feel more energetic i wouldn't say i
feel like i have more energy you know i
actually get up feeling energized and
ready to kind of get my day going in one
week i've lost about six and a half
pounds already
i'm here to
turn things around and gonna try some
gluten-free pizza tonight
it's like pizza made on um two thick
tortillas and they're sweet for some
reason it's not a substitute for normal
pizza better than i thought of a feeling
that is going to be the standard review
for gluten-free food it kind of tastes
like pizza minus bread like i can't
taste the crust at all so i can tell
that my body's no longer used to eating
gluten but i don't know if i'm
losing a lot of weight or like feeling
amazingly better i haven't seen my
energy level change i've seen my anger
and frustration level change wow
what an amazing snack it's been pretty
fantastic i've just found myself like
walking a lot more you know like not
feeling like i need to take a nap in the
middle of the day so my friend's
engagement
i'm still doing gluten-free so you can
see my entire plate is pretty much empty
besides lentils and rice it's one of
those things that i feel like i could
continue doing even after this is over
my goal was to just help my girlfriend
get used to celiac disease and she
hasn't had gluten in maybe three or four
months which is huge for her so that
worked out really well nutritionists are
really good at making gluten-free diets
sound fun when they're actually awful it
was too big of an inconvenience i don't
think i really feel any different at all
there's gluten and weird things that you
wouldn't expect like i realized sort of
halfway through that my face lotion had
gluten in it now i found that you know i
don't really feel bogged down by the
stuff i've eaten from the previous day
even just the breakfast i'm having it's
a lot lighter i just feel like uh you
know i've actually got energy to get
through the day
lost five pounds all right i lost five
pounds i don't have a lot of body fat
i'm not sure if i can afford to lose
five pounds three pounds of body fat
three pounds of body fat
oh
that's cool i cannot wait to eat gluten
again internet do you know this do you
know how good pizza is it's so good
it's so good it was worth it just for
this plate of a cupcake and a pizza this
is everything i could have asked for and
it just made it that much better after
not having it for a month
you